This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When I look at a body of water, I assume that it's teeming with microbes. And for that reason, I wouldn't fill my water bottle from a puddle or a pond or probably even a stream because I know that I have a chance of getting a waterborne disease. But I don't apply the same scrutiny to the air I breathe, which is a little odd because it too is chock full of life. Scientists call it the aerobiome.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。当我看着一片水体时，我就会想里面一定挤满了微生物。正因如此，我不会从水坑、池塘甚至小溪里装水瓶，因为我知道自己有可能感染水传播疾病。但我不会对呼吸的空气抱有同样的审视，这有点奇怪，因为它同样充满了生命。科学家们称之为空气微生物组。
It's this huge ecosystem that we really barely understand at all. This is science writer Carl Zimmer, who has written an amazing new book called Airborne, all about the life that is wafting about in the air all around us. The aeroboom is not just important for how nature itself works, but you are breathing in living things. things pretty much with every breath. You know, most of the time they don't kill you.
这是一个我们几乎完全不了解的巨大生态系统。说话的是科学作家卡尔·齐默，他写了一本名为《空气中》的精彩新书，讲述的全是我们周围空气中飘浮的生命。空气微生物组不仅对大自然本身的运作至关重要，而且你每次呼吸时，几乎都在吸入活的生物。你知道，大多数时候它们不会要了你的命。
But, you know, when you have a pandemic, sometimes a lot of people do die. Carl Zimmer's book is a scientific history of the air and its relationship to disease. I started reading the book for fun, but I decided to interview Carl on the show because it actually has a lot to do with architecture. Most of our breathing happens indoors,
但是，你知道，当你经历大流行时，有时确实会有很多人死亡。卡尔·齐默的书是一部空气及其与疾病关系的科学史。我一开始读这本书只是为了消遣，但我决定在节目中采访卡尔，因为它实际上与建筑学有很大关系。我们大部分的呼吸都是在室内进行的，
and yet modern architects rarely designed buildings with airborne disease in mind. Carl Zimmer thinks that's in part because for over a century, scientific institutions have been reluctant to take the air seriously as an important vector for disease. We got a taste of this during the early days of the COVID-19 pandemic, when there was a lot of conflict and confusion about whether the virus was airborne and what airborne even means. But this conflict and confusion, it didn't start in 2020. I mean, the fact is that our struggle to understand the air and what the air means to us and our health actually goes back thousands of years.
然而现代建筑师在设计建筑物时却很少考虑空气传播疾病。卡尔·齐默认为，部分原因是了一个多世纪以来，科学机构一直不愿认真对待空气作为疾病的重要传播媒介。我们在新冠疫情初期就对此深有体会，当时关于该病毒是否通过空气传播以及空气传播到底意味着什么，存在着很多冲突和困惑。但这种冲突和困惑并非始于 2020 年。我的意思是，事实上，我们对空气以及空气对我们和健康的意义的理解，其实可以追溯到几千年前。
So, okay, so I want you to guide us through this history of how we think about the error and its relationship to disease. So where should we start? Well, if you go way back to the ancient world, there were a lot of concepts about the air being the cause of many diseases. And so Hippocrates would talk about myasmas, which were like a corruption of the air. You know, why is it that all these people in this village all got the plague around the same time? Well, it must be because there was a miasma in the air that just
好吧，那么我想请你带领我们了解这段历史，了解我们如何看待空气及其与疾病的关系。那么我们该从哪里开始呢？嗯，如果你追溯到古代世界，就会有很多关于空气是许多疾病之源的概念。因此，希波克拉底会谈论瘴气，这就像空气的腐败。你知道，为什么这个村子里的所有人几乎在同一时间都感染了瘟疫？嗯，那一定是因为空气中有一种瘴气，刚好
traveled along and everybody inhaled it and they all died. So there was this powerful concept, which held on in one way or another for many, many centuries. Could you describe what was the conception of what a miasma was? Like, what was it made of? Like, I don't quite get it. Of course you don't get it because you don't live in ancient Greece and you don't have an ancient Greek worldview, you know? I mean, you got to think about the world as being made of four elements. So you have to think about your body is being made of four humors. I mean, it takes a lot of rejiggering to really try to even begin to understand what Hippocrates is talking about. It's a corruption. Corruption was a very powerful idea in ancient Western thought in
随风飘散，每个人都吸了进去，然后他们都死了。因此，这个强有力的概念在许多、许多世纪里以这样或那样的方式一直存在着。你能描述一下对瘴气的概念是怎样的吗？比如，它是由什么组成的？呃，我不太明白。你当然不明白，因为你不住在古希腊，也没有古希腊的世界观，你知道吗？我的意思是，你必须认为世界是由四种元素组成的。所以你必须认为你的身体是由四种体液组成的。我的意思是，要真正开始理解希波克拉底在说什么，需要进行大量的调整。这是一种腐败。在古代西方思想中，腐败是一个非常强有力的概念，
particular. And so, you know, you would have the four humors in your body, which were in this delicate balance. And, you know, if you inhale this corrupted air, that would throw your humors out of balance. Actually, yeah, like myasmas were believed to be caused by lots of different things. So they might be caused by bad weather. They might be caused by the stars. They might be caused by waste lying on the ground or stagnant water. So there are all these potential sources for corrupting the air. And then when you breathed it in, then you would get sick. And there were different myasmas for different diseases. You know, plague, influenza, so on and on and on. Each one, had its own miasma.
尤其是。所以，你知道，你体内会有四种体液，它们处于这种微妙的平衡中。而且，你知道，如果你吸入了这种腐化的空气，就会打破你体内的体液平衡。事实上，是的，人们认为瘴气是由许多不同的事情引起的。所以它们可能是由恶劣天气引起的。它们可能是由星星引起的。它们可能是由地面上的垃圾或死水引起的。因此，所有这些都是腐化空气的潜在来源。然后当你吸入它时，你就会生病。不同的疾病有不同的瘴气。你知道，鼠疫、流感，诸如此类，没完没了。每一种疾病都有它自己的瘴气。
So how did thinking about disease as a myasma affect the way people behaved? Myasma would actually affect the way people built their world, the way that cities were designed and the way that houses were built. So canals would be built, you know, so that you didn't have water just getting stagnant. Waste would be required to be cleared out of the center of cities. When you had reform movements in Britain in the 1700s that were trying to improve the health of people in prisons, people were dying in prisons of diseases, including something they were called jail fever. They thought what you needed to do was to bring in fresh air because wholesome fresh air would replace the stagnant air that, you know, filled with myasmas that was building up inside these prisons. And so there was even a British prison that had a windmill built on the roof to try to circulate fresh air through the whole building. And so a lot of the response to this belief in
那么，将疾病视为瘴气如何影响了人们的行为呢？瘴气实际上会影响人们建立世界的方式、城市的规划方式以及房屋的建造方式。因此人们会建造运河，你知道的，这样就不会有死水积存。人们被要求清理城市中心的垃圾。当你在 18 世纪的英国发起旨在改善监狱犯人健康的改革运动时，人们死于监狱中的疾病，包括一种被称为狱热的疾病。他们认为你需要做的是引入新鲜空气，因为健康的新鲜空气将取代那些充满瘴气、积聚在这些监狱内部的死水般的空气。因此，甚至还有一座英国监狱在屋顶上建了一个风车，试图让新鲜空气在整栋建筑中循环。因此，对这种信仰的许多反应是
myasmas was urban planning and architecture. I want to bring in this character, or this person that is a character in your book named Max von Pettencalfer. Can you tell me about him and where he sits in the miasma world? So Max von Pettencalfer was the last great defender of miasmas. He was born in 1818, and he died in 1901, and pretty much to the end, he was arguing and fighting passionately for miasmas as being the cause of diseases like cholera and typhoid and on and on and on. In his day, he was not considered a crank. In fact, just the opposite. He was revered. He was considered the world. expert on cholera. And so what were Van Pettankoffer's ideas about cholera?
瘴气体现在城市规划和建筑上。我想引入这个角色，或者说你书中的一个人物，名叫马克斯·冯·佩滕科弗。你能跟我讲讲他以及他在瘴气世界中的地位吗？马克斯·冯·佩滕科弗是瘴气的最后一位伟大捍卫者。他生于 1818 年，卒于 1901 年，几乎到最后，他都还在充满激情地为瘴气辩护和抗争，认为瘴气是霍乱、伤寒等各种疾病的起因，没完没了。在当时，他并不被认为是个怪人。事实上，恰恰相反。他备受尊崇。他被认为是世界霍乱专家。那么，冯·佩滕科弗对霍乱有什么看法呢？
Colora comes to Europe in the 19th century. In this series of epidemics, they're totally terrifying. A city would be running along smoothly and everything seemed fine one day. And the next day, people are just dropping dead in the street. Their faces are turning blue. They are suffering violent cramps and diarrhea. And within a few days, they're dead. You know, thousands and thousands and thousands of people are dying in city after city after city. So what is it? So Van Pentecofer believed that cholera was actually caused by fumes that came out of the ground, that there were the certain kinds of bacteria that could ferment, basically, in soil that was damp and just had just the right conditions.
霍乱在 19 世纪传入欧洲。在这一系列流行病中，它们完全令人毛骨悚然。一座城市本来运行得很顺利，有一天一切看起来都很好。而第二天，人们就纷纷倒在街头。他们的脸变蓝了。他们遭受着剧烈的痉挛和腹泻。几天之内，他们就死了。你知道，成千上万的人在越来越多的城市里死去。那么，这到底是什么？所以，冯·佩滕科弗认为，霍乱实际上是由从地下冒出的气味引起的，在潮湿且具备恰当条件的土壤中，某些特定种类的细菌基本上可以发酵。
So you would have these fumes that they would release and they would be. build up inside of buildings, inside of people's homes, especially if they were poorly ventilated. So people would, you know, be breathing this stuff in and out, in and out, and it would create damage inside their bodies that would eventually trigger all the horrible, deadly symptoms of cholera. And so he was very concerned to keep the air safe. So what were his ideas about how to do that, about how to keep the air safe? Well, he believed that, that, that you have to prevent these fumes from reaching people. So one way you can do that is to try to avoid the circumstances
因此，它们会释放出这些气体，并在建筑物内部、人们的家中积聚，特别是如果通风不良的话。因此，人们会不断地吸入和呼出这些东西，这会在他们体内造成损害，最终引发霍乱所有可怕的、致命的症状。因此，他非常关注如何保持空气安全。那么，他关于如何做到这一点的想法是什么，关于如何保持空气安全？好吧，他认为，你必须防止这些气味到达人们身边。所以你可以采取的一种方法是尽量避免这种情况
in which these fumes can form. You can build buildings on soil that he believed was safer, for example. He made lots of changes in Munich to the water system so that you wouldn't have a lot of stagnant water sitting around, which he believed that would be a problem. he emphasizes ventilation. You want to get fresh air moving through your house or your office or your school. Because if there's no way for air to get out, these fumes that he imagined were rising up from the ground are just going to get into these rooms and get trapped in there.
这些气味可能在这种情况下形成。例如，你可以在他认为更安全的土壤上建造建筑物。他对慕尼黑的供水系统进行了大量改造，这样就不会有大量死水滞留，他认为那会是个问题。他强调通风。你希望让新鲜空气在你的房子、办公室或学校里流通。因为如果空气无法排出，他想象中从地下升起的气味就会进入这些房间并被困在里面。
And then you just breathe them and breathe them and breathe them. And he was part of a movement. You know, they called themselves sanitarians and they wanted to help everyone. And so, you know, tenements in New York or hospitals for the poor in London or what have you, they were all trying to get fresh air to people. They were all trying to fight miasmas and thereby fight disease. I mean, you wrote that the New York City Board of Health forced the installation of 46,000 new windows throughout the city, which sounds, that's something, that's an intense buy-in. I mean, that's a very expensive proposition. Yeah, absolutely.
然后你就一遍又一遍地呼吸着它们。他是一场运动的一部分。你知道，他们称自己为卫生改革者，他们想帮助所有人。所以，你知道，纽约的廉租公寓、伦敦穷人的医院等等，他们都在努力为人们提供新鲜空气。他们都在努力对抗瘴气，从而对抗疾病。我的意思是，你写道，纽约市卫生局强制在全市安装了 46,000 扇新窗户，这听起来，这可真了不起，这是一个巨大的投入。我的意思是，这是一个非常昂贵的提议。是的，绝对的。
Absolutely. I mean, you know, New York was much smaller of a city at the time. So that is just huge. Yeah. These sanitarians and these reformers were able to get a lot of things pushed through. And, you know, Florence Nightingale was very much part of this movement as well. And she designed new kinds of hospitals with long corridors and rooms branching off of them, all designed to maximize the flow of air, to get fresh air. into for these patients because she was convinced that they were getting sick, not from contagious disease, but from myasmas. So as popular as the myasma theory was, the idea that bad vibes or animal carcasses or stagnant water was corrupting the air with poisonous fumes was obviously wrong. And over time, you get this competing philosophy, which is germ theory, which we now know is correct. Can you talk about how germ theorists started to win the battle of ideas against sanitarians like von Pettenkofer? You know, in the 1600s, people are starting to invent microscopes. And when they look through the microscopes, they suddenly discover there are all these
绝对的。我的意思是，你知道，当时纽约是一座小得多的城市。所以这真是太巨大了。是的。这些卫生改革者和改革家能够推动许多事情的落实。而且，你知道，弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔也是这场运动的重要组成部分，她设计了新型医院，里面有长长的走廊和分支的病房，所有这些都是为了最大限度地提高空气流通，将新鲜空气引入
tiny creatures that we didn't know about before. They would call them germs or microbes or, you know, bacteria. They had all sorts of names for these things. And as early as the early 1700s, you had people saying, you know, these germs are the cause of diseases, like plague and tuberculosis and on and on and on. And they got to be known as the contagionists. And everyone thought they were crazy. But slowly in the 19th century, the evidence started to accrue that, yeah, actually, there are particular microbes, species of microbes that can cause particular diseases. And by the late 1800s, there's a German scientist named Robert Koch, who is really starting to nail one disease after another. And he establishes a link between one
这些患者，因为她确信他们生病不是因为传染病，而是因为瘴气。尽管瘴气理论很受欢迎，但坏气味、动物尸体或死水正在用有毒气体污染空气的想法显然是错误的。随着时间的推移，你迎来了这一竞争哲学，也就是我们现在知道正确的细菌理论。你能谈谈细菌论者是如何开始赢得针对像冯·佩滕科弗这样的卫生学家的思想之战的吗？你知道，在 17 世纪，人们开始发明显微镜。当他们通过显微镜观察时，他们突然发现有所有这些
kind of bacteria and cholera. So this thing that Maximum Pettenkofer was saying, oh, this is a choleraa, it's caused by these fumes. You've got to be careful about the air that you breathe and blah, blah, blah. Robert Koch is saying, no. it's caused by this bacteria. You know, I find it in people's stool who are sick with cholera. You know, when there's an outbreak in a village and I go to a water tank in India, I find the same bacteria in there. Like, this is, this is it.
我们以前不知道的小生物。他们称它们为病菌、微生物或细菌。它们有各种各样的名字。早在 18 世纪初，就有人说，你知道，这些病菌是鼠疫、肺结核等疾病的起因。它们被称为传染论者。每个人都认为他们疯了。但慢慢地在 19 世纪，证据开始累积，是的，实际上，确实有特定的微生物、微生物物种可以引起特定的疾病。到 19 世纪末，有一个名叫罗伯特·科赫的德国科学家，他真正开始一个接一个地锁定疾病。他建立了一种联系
And it is spread through water. The last great cholera outbreak was in the 19th century in Europe, was in Hamburg in 1892. And Robert Koch, like, comes in there and says, okay, we have got to deal with this as it really is. as a waterborne microbe. And he brought in clean water. He disinfected houses, so and so forth. The epidemic ended, and national laws were put in place to follow these rules to ensure clean water, you know, to make sure our water doesn't make us sick.
某种细菌和霍乱。所以马克斯·冯·佩滕科弗一直在说，哦，这是霍乱，是由这些气体引起的。你必须小心你呼吸的空气等等，罗伯特·科赫说，不，这是由这种细菌引起的。你知道，我在患霍乱的病人的粪便中发现了它。你知道，当一个村庄爆发疫情时，我去印度的水箱，我在那里发现了同样的细菌。就像，就是这个。
Yeah. And Bon Pencroft refused to accept this. He just kept fighting with Coke over and over again. And now he's like in his 70s, like, no, no, no, no, no. I mean, so much so that he, like, ingests a bunch of cholera just to prove his point. Like, he really put his money where his mouth is. Yeah, right in his mouth that you could say. I mean, what happened was that Von Pettnkopfer sends a very mysterious note to a colleague of Robert Koch in Hamburg.
它是通过水传播的。19 世纪欧洲最后一次大霍乱爆发是在 1892 年的汉堡。罗伯特·科赫来到那里说，好吧，我们必须将其作为它本来面目来处理，作为一种水传播的微生物。他带来了干净的水。他给房屋消毒，诸如此类。疫情结束了，国家通过了法律来遵循这些规则以确保水质清洁，你知道，以确保我们的水不会让我们生病。
Says something along the lines of it. I would like to have a sample of this bacteria for my own study. so they send it to him and he gets up one morning and then he goes to a lecture hall and he brings together all of his acolytes and in front of them he declares holding up this tube that he is going to drink it he's going to prove once and for all that cholera is not caused by bacteria that it is you know that it is this this airborne miasma disease and you know his students are like no no no let let us do it for you and he's like no no no No. He says, I should die in the cause of science like a soldier on the field of honor.
是的。而冯·佩滕科弗拒绝接受这一点。他只是一次又一次地与科赫争吵。现在他已经 70 多岁了，还说，不，不，不，不。我的意思是，甚至到了这种地步，他为了证明自己的观点，竟然吞下了一堆霍乱弧菌。就像，他真的用行动证明了自己。是的，可以说就直接吞进嘴里了。我的意思是，发生的事情是，冯·佩滕科弗给罗伯特·科赫在汉堡的一位同事发了一封非常神秘的便条。
He was such a dramatic person. He actually, like, tried to be an actor when he was young. He ran off from pharmacy school for a year and was in the theater and then decided that wasn't going to work. But he never lost a dramatic streak. So he's putting on this performance and he kicks it back. And over the next couple days, he doesn't feel great, but he gets over. And he sends a note to Robert Koch, you know, declaring that he was in good health, just wanted Coke to know. But what Pettencalford didn't know is that when he asked for the bacteria that causes cholera, Coke and his pals kind of had an idea of what he wanted. And they're like, hmm, what do we do? And amazingly, weirdly, you know, they said, let's give him some
大致意思是，我想要一份这种细菌的样本来进行我自己的研究。所以他们把它寄给了他，他第二天早上起床，来到一个演讲厅，召集了他的所有门徒，在他们面前，他举起这根试管宣布他要喝下它，他要彻底证明霍乱不是由细菌引起的，你知道的，它是这种空气传播的瘴气疾病，你知道，他的学生说，不，不，不，让我们为你代劳吧，而他说，不，不，不。他说，我应该像战场上的士兵一样，为科学事业而死。
bacteria isolated from someone who had very mild symptoms, someone who did not die. So they took pity on him. They didn't tell him what they had done, but they had just said, like, oh, just give him a harmless strain, which he then drank and thought that he had proved at last that my asthma were real. But by then, you know, the evidence was just piling up and piling up and piling up. And, you know, he got very depressed. And it's a very sad story. In 1901, he shot himself. He committed suicide. And, you know, the obituaries were polite at first, but eventually as the germ theory of disease really took hold and myasmas really started to look like like an embarrassing vestige of a superstitious age, Pettenkofer was lost to history. People would just say he is
他是一个很有戏剧性的人。他年轻时实际上还尝试过当演员。他从药学院退学一年，在剧院里待过，后来觉得行不通。但他从来没有失去戏剧性的特质。所以他在进行这场表演，然后一饮而尽。在接下来的几天里，他感觉不太好，但挺过来了。他给罗伯特·科赫发了一便条，宣称自己身体健康，只是想让科赫知道。但佩滕科弗不知道的是，当他索要引起霍乱的细菌时，科赫和他的伙伴们大致猜到了他想要什么。他们想，嗯，我们该怎么办？令人惊奇的是，诡异的是，你知道，他们说，让我们给他一些
just a, one journal said he's just a shadow of a name. He was gone. So I'm struck by a certain irony when it comes to von Pettincoffer and the whole myasma theory, which is, you know, the underlying science is complete nonsense, but some of his ideas about how to keep people healthy, particularly his focus on ventilation and clean air, actually do make sense in the context of airborne infections like tuberculosis or COVID-19. I mean, can you talk about that weird irony of being so wrong, but like right enough that, you know, things are actually made better, you know, in the built world and for people's health? Yeah.
从症状非常轻微、没有死的人身上分离出来的细菌。所以他们对他产生了一点怜悯。他们没有告诉他他们做了什么，只是说，哦，就给他一个无害的菌株吧，然后他喝下了它，以为自己终于证明了瘴气是真实的。但到那时，你知道，证据不断堆积、堆积、堆积。而且，你知道，他变得非常沮丧。这是一个非常悲伤的故事。1901年，他开枪自杀了。他自杀了。而且，你知道，讣告起初还算礼貌，但最终随着疾病的细菌理论真正扎根，瘴气真的开始看起来像迷信时代的尴尬遗迹，佩滕科弗在历史上消失了。人们只会说他是
It's strange that, you know, we think that when, you know, people are wrong, they're just wrong, wrong. And we think about the history of science as giving up wrong ideas to embrace the right ideas. Yeah. And, you know, those people who were wrong, they're, you know, cast back into history. as being the wrong ones. Right.
只是，正如一家期刊所说，他只是一个名字的影子。他消失了。因此，谈到冯·佩滕科弗和整个瘴气理论时，我被某种讽刺意味所震撼，那就是，你知道，其背后的科学完全是无稽之谈，但他关于如何保持人们健康的某些想法，特别是他对通风和新鲜空气的关注，在诸如结核病或新冠肺炎等空气传播感染的背景下确实有道理。我的意思是，你能谈谈那种奇怪的讽刺吗？错得如此离谱，却又足够正确，以至于在现实世界中和为了人们的健康，事情确实得到了改善？是的。
And their ideas, we would think of them as just nothing but superstition. And the idea that cholera or typhoid was something that was caused by you inhaling fumes, that's wrong. That's really wrong. And if you were to try to protect yourself from cholera or typhoid that way, you would be so wrong, you'd be dead. Right. And yet, you know, the idea that the air can kill you with some of these infectious diseases, that's true. That's absolutely true. And in some ways, we would do very well to go back to the ideas of people like Max von Pettncalfour and learn a lot from them.
这很奇怪，你知道，我们认为当人们犯错时，他们就是错的，彻底的错误。我们认为科学史就是放弃错误的思想去拥抱正确的思想。是的。而且，你知道，那些犯错的人，他们被抛回到历史中，被视为错误的一方。对。
To learn about the importance of fresh air, of clean air, of ventilation, all these things that. Crawford was developing in the 1860s. He was right in a lot of ways, as wrong as he was in other ways. Coming up after the break, Carl Zimmer and I talk about how in the 20th century, our perception of the air totally flipped, and we went from being too scared of the air to not scared enough. Okay, so we're back with Carl Zimmer, and we just got done talking about the end of the miasma theory of disease in the late 1800s. So let's fast forward a little bit into the 1930s and 40s. By this point, there was broad acceptance that germs were causing diseases. And scientists thought
他们的想法，我们会认为除了迷信别无他物。认为霍乱或伤寒是由吸入气体引起的想法是错误的。这大错特错。如果你试图用这种方法保护自己免受霍乱或伤寒的侵害，你会错得离谱，连命都没了。对。然而，你知道，空气中的某些传染病会致死这一观点是真的。这绝对是真的。在某些方面，我们最好回到像马克斯·冯·佩滕科弗这样的人的想法中，并从中吸取很多教训。
you might spread germs by coughing saliva particles right into someone's face, but they didn't think that germs could float around in the air like smoke. That's right. So by the early 1900s, public health experts generally feel that, you know, they've got a handle on how diseases spread. And they're just of a few basic ways. Either they're spreading by contact, they're, you know, contaminated surfaces, sex, contaminated food. contaminated water, that's about it. And the air, which had been so dominant for many, many centuries, now, you know, in the words of some of these public health experts, it was basically harmless. And, you know, somebody even said, like, we should be relieved. That's great. We don't
了解新鲜空气、清洁空气、通风的重要性，所有这些佩滕科弗在 18 世纪 60 年代开发的这些东西。尽管他在其他方面大错特错，但在很多方面他确实是正确的。中场休息之后，卡尔·齐默和我将讨论在 20 世纪，我们对空气的看法发生了怎样的彻底转变，我们从对空气过度恐惧转变为恐惧不足。好了，我们欢迎卡尔·齐默回归，我们刚刚讨论完 19 世纪末疾病瘴气理论的终结。那么让我们快进一点到 20 世纪 30 年代和 40 年代。到这个时候，人们已经普遍接受细菌会引起疾病。科学家们认为
have to have to worry about these myasms as a way that, you know, generations and generations were worried about it. Relax. The air is fine. But in your book, you talk about these two scientists who started to really question whether that was actually true. Yeah. William and Mildred Wells in the 1930s, this husband and wife team, said, wait a minute, like, that's not right. And, you know, they develop the basic ideas and the basic concepts for how actually airborne transmission really works. They understood that when we exhale, we're exhaling tiny droplets all the time.
你可能会通过将唾液颗粒咳嗽到别人的脸上来传播细菌，但他们并不认为细菌可以像烟雾一样在空气中四处漂浮。没错。因此，到 20 世纪初，公共卫生专家普遍认为，你知道，他们已经掌握了疾病是如何传播的。而且只有几种基本途径。要么是通过接触传播，你知道的，被污染的表面、性、被污染的食物、被污染的水，差不多就是这样。而空气，在许多、许多世纪里一直占主导地位，现在，用其中一些公共卫生专家的话说，基本上是无害的。而且，你知道，甚至有人说，我们应该松一口气。太好了。我们不需要
You don't have to be coughing or sneezing. And they might have viruses or bacteria in them. And if they're small enough, they'll just float along. And if you're in a poorly ventilated room, they're going to be hanging around with you. And as people keep exhaling those droplets with the bacteria and the viruses in them, those concentrations are going to increase. And so your risk of getting a disease from these airborne germs will increase. And because myasmas were so out of fashion at this point, did they sort of fight, have to fight? the stigma of being like called myasmistists or something like that.
担心这些瘴气会成为几代人一直担心的方式。放松点。空气很好。但在你的书中，你谈到了这两位科学家，他们开始真正质疑这是否属实。是的，20 世纪 30 年代的威廉和米尔德里德·韦尔斯，这对夫妻档说，等等，这不对。而且，你知道，他们为空气传播实际上是如何运作的奠定了基本思想和基本概念。他们明白，当我们呼气时，我们一直在呼出微小的飞沫。
They did. They did. They actually wrote. We're not talking about myasmas. We're not myasmatists. Please, like listen to us. Listen to what we have to say. And don't dismiss us as if we were from 400 years ago. We're talking about real physics right now and based on real experiments. And this could be a major source of disease. They were concerned for example, that the influenza pandemic of 1918, which had killed 50 million people, they were saying, you know, that might have been airborne. And, you know, tuberculosis, one of the biggest killers year in, you're out. They were saying, we think this is airborne too.
你不需要咳嗽或打喷嚏。它们可能含有病毒或细菌。如果它们足够小，就会四处漂浮。如果你在一个通风不良的房间里，它们就会和你待在一起。随着人们不断呼出含有细菌和病毒的飞沫，这些浓度将会增加。因此，你从这些空气传播的病菌中感染疾病的风险将会增加。而且因为瘴气在这个时候已经非常过时了，他们是否必须抗争、必须克服诸如被称为瘴气论者之类的不良名声？
And we're not talking about mysterious my answers. We are germ theorists. There are germs that are doing this, but they're going through the air. They're traveling through the air. And you can stop them in the air. But despite Mildred and William Wells' research showing that, certain diseases were traveling through the air, the scientific establishment remains pretty reluctant to jump on the idea of airborne infection. And this remains true really up until the 21st
他们确实如此。他们确实如此。他们甚至写道：我们不是在谈论瘴气。我们不是瘴气论者。请听听我们的话。听听我们要说的话。不要把我们当成是 400 年前的人而Dismiss我们。我们现在谈论的是真正的物理学，而且是基于真正的实验。这可能是疾病的主要来源。例如，他们担心 1918 年杀死了 5000 万人的流感大流行，他们说，你知道，那可能是通过空气传播的。而且，你知道，结核病，年复一年最大的杀手之一。他们说，我们认为这也是通过空气传播的。
century. Yeah. William Wells dies in 1963 and, you know, there's a tiny little obituary for him, but his work is pretty much forgotten right after that, except for a few people that are trying to sort of carry on his memory and his ideas, but for the most part, it's forgotten. And in 2003, in China and in Hong Kong, suddenly there's this pneumonia that breaks out, SARS that, you know, can cause quite a lot of people to die in its spreading in strange ways. You know, there was an outbreak in a hospital where there were cases that went, you know, new cases that cropped up all the way down a ward from a patient, like a long distance. And people were like, well, how is this happening?
我们谈论的不是神秘的瘴气。我们是细菌论者。有细菌在这样做，但它们是通过空气传播的。它们在空气中传播。你可以在空气中阻止它们。尽管米尔德里德和威廉·韦尔斯的研究表明某些疾病是通过空气传播的，但科学界仍然非常不愿意接受空气传播感染的想法。这种情况一直持续到 21 世纪
And there was an apartment block where lots of people were getting sick, so much so that this giant apartment block had to be emptied out. People were sent off outside of Hong Kong so that the building could be disinfected. And so as a few scientists started to look carefully at that and think about that. And how do you get that sort of spread? They're like, ways we talk about don't, they don't make sense. And they started to dig into this old, old literature about airborne disease, William and Mildred Wells, who they had not heard of.
世纪。是的。威廉·韦尔斯于 1963 年去世，你知道，有一篇关于他的极短的讣告，但他的工作在那之后几乎就被遗忘了，除了少数人试图继承他的记忆和他的想法外，大部分都被遗忘了。2003 年，在中国和香港，突然爆发了这种肺炎，非典（SARS），你知道的，它会导致相当多的人死亡，并且以奇怪的方式传播。你知道，有一家医院爆发了疫情，病例从病房的一个患者开始，一路传播到很远的地方，出现了新病例。人们就在想，这怎么可能发生？
Like, they had to rediscover these folks and say like, huh, this seems like this explains it. It seems like SARS is airborne. And so you had this small group of people in the early 2000s who were studying SARS, who were studying influenza, who were actually trying to capture the droplets coming out of people's mouths and actually finding those viruses that were in the droplets and they were doing this very basic research, but pretty much ignored by public health community. They just kept saying, no, no, no, this doesn't matter. This can't happen. It's not airborne. They just wouldn't accept it right up through into the COVID pandemic. Yeah. And I still just like, why? Why do you think scientific institutions have been so reluctant,
还有一个公寓楼，许多人生病，以至于这座巨大的公寓楼不得不被清空。人们被送到香港境外，以便对建筑物进行消毒。随着一些科学家开始仔细研究和思考这个问题。你怎么能得到那种传播？他们说，我们谈论的方式说不通。他们开始挖掘关于空气传播疾病的这些陈旧的文献，威廉和米尔德里德·韦尔斯，他们以前从未听说过。
to see airborne infection for what it is. I mean, because, I mean, when you say this is happening in 2003 and then developing, you know, up until today, it's just like, usually you read science history books and you go, oh, those dummies didn't know anything back then or whatever, and you're like, it's so obvious now and that this is a fight that's brought right to our contemporary doorstep is so shocking to me.
就像，他们不得不重新发现这些人并说，哈，这似乎解释了这一切。看起来非典是通过空气传播的。因此，在 2000 年代初期，有一小群人研究非典，研究流感，他们实际上试图捕获人们嘴里喷出的飞沫，并实际找到了飞沫中的那些病毒，他们正在做这种非常基础的研究，但基本上被公共卫生界忽视了。他们只是不断地说，不，不，不，这没关系。这不可能发生。它不是空气传播的。他们就是不接受，直到新冠大流行。是的。而且我依然觉得，为什么？你认为为什么科学机构如此不情愿，
Yes, it's certainly like working on this book. was just really vexing in the sense of like I'd be reading things from the 1930s where I'm like, oh, right, yeah, like, okay, like all this stuff that we've learned in the past few years about airborne disease, like we didn't learn this. We weren't the first, you know? Like people were understanding this stuff in the 30s. And it wasn't a secret in the 30s either. You know, there were newspaper articles about William and Mildred Wells. Not only had they established that diseases might be able to spread through the air, but they could kill them in the air.
去认清空气传播感染的本质。我的意思是，因为，当你说是 2003 年发生这种情况，然后一直在发展，你知道，直到今天，就像，通常你读科学历史书，然后你会说，哦，那些笨蛋当时什么也不知道，或者诸如此类，而你会想，现在这么明显，而且这是一场直接被带到我们当代门口的斗争，这让我感到非常震惊。
They discovered that ultraviolet light could disinfect the air. And so you had an article saying, oh, like, we are going to be protected in the future. Schools and theaters and hospitals and public spaces will be protected by ultraviolet light. So we don't have to worry about things like the 1918 flu pandemic in the future. This is what people were thinking in the 1930s. And then it went away. You know, these are powerful, durable ideas that take hold and don't move very easily. Right.
是的，这确实，编写这本书的过程真的让人很烦恼，因为我会阅读 20 世纪 30 年代的东西，心想，哦，对了，是的，好吧，就像我们在过去几年里关于空气传播疾病所学到的所有这些东西，我们并不是第一个学到的，你知道吗？就像人们在 30 年代就理解了这些东西。而且在 30 年代也不是什么秘密。你知道，有关于威廉和米尔德里德·韦尔斯的报纸文章。他们不仅确定了疾病可以通过空气传播，而且他们还可以在空气中杀死它们。
And we saw this persistent reluctance to embrace the reality of airborne infection as recently as five years ago during the early days of the COVID pandemic. I don't know. Part of me felt like the reason the public health officials didn't want to declare that COVID was airborne was just because they knew that our society was so ill-prepared to deal with. disease like that? There are things you can do, but it takes a lot of work. And so if you treat a disease as if it is only spread through contact or through very large droplets that only go a very short distance, you know, three feet or something like that, there are things that you can do both in hospitals and in the community that are pretty straightforward. You know, you just, you just tell people like, okay, you know, if you're not feeling well, you know, stay at
他们发现紫外线可以对空气进行消毒。所以有一篇文章说，哦，就像，我们将来会受到保护。学校、剧院、医院和公共空间将受到紫外线的保护。所以我们将来不必担心像 1918 年流感大流行那样的事情。这就是 20 世纪 30 年代人们的想法。然后它消失了。你知道，这些都是强大而持久的想法，一旦扎根就不会轻易改变。对。
home. If you see someone who's sick, keep an arm's link for them and you'll be fine, you know. Whereas if you are dealing with an airborne disease that is raging through your community, you've got to like deal with that really seriously on another level. Because the, because now the air itself effectively is making people sick. And so you have to deal with the air as a whole. And that's not something that people are eager to embrace. Yeah. We're all like the mayor of Amity, you know, island. And we're just not willing to accept that Jaws is here. You know what I mean? Because it's just, it's too much to handle, you know? That's right. And I mean, I'm not just inferring this, you know, the fact is that during the COVID pandemic, when there were scientists who
我们看到这种对接受空气传播感染现实的持续抗拒，就在五年前的新冠大流行初期。我不知道。我的一部分感觉是，公共卫生官员不想宣布新冠是通过空气传播的，只是因为他们知道我们的社会对应对这种疾病毫无准备？你可以做一些事情，但这需要大量的努力。因此，如果你将一种疾病视为仅通过接触或仅传播很短距离（三英尺左右）的非常大的飞沫传播，那么你在医院和社区中可以做的事情就相当简单了。你知道，你只要告诉人们，好吧，你知道，如果你感觉不舒服，就呆在
were saying this thing looks airborne and you, the World Health Organization, need to treat it that way, the World Health Organization responded to them saying, we are not going to tell countries with limited health care budgets that they're going to have to go spend it all to deal with big airborne control systems when, you know, we're not entirely convinced of it. People actually said this out loud. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
家里。如果你看到有人生病，和他们保持一臂的距离，你就会没事的，你知道。然而，如果你面对的是一种在你的社区中肆虐的空气传播疾病，你必须在另一个层面上非常认真地对待它。因为现在空气本身实际上在让人生病。所以你必须将空气作为一个整体来处理。这不是人们渴望接受的事情。是的。我们都像阿米蒂岛的市长一样，你知道。我们就是不愿接受大白鲨已经来了。你知道我的意思吗？因为这实在太难以应付了，你知道吗？没错。我的意思是，我不仅仅是在推断这一点，你知道，事实是，在新冠大流行期间，当一些科学家
Those beaches will be open on July 4th, is what they said. Basically. So it took way too long, but eventually we recognized COVID-19 as an airborne infection. And that recognition led to some changes in our behavior, you know,
说这个东西看起来是通过空气传播的，你们世界卫生组织需要这样对待它，世界卫生组织对他们的回应是，我们不会告诉医疗保健预算有限的国家，当你知道我们还没有完全确信它时，他们必须把钱都花在处理大型空气控制系统上。人们居然大声说出了这种话。对，对，对。
like outdoor dining and masks. but you personally had a change in your lifestyle that I think is pretty neat. Can you talk about the little device that you now carry around with you to help you measure the level of ventilation in indoor spaces? I have a carbon dioxide meter that I keep with me, and I'm looking at it now. So when we started talking, I had the window open just because it's a nice day here, and it was at 441 parts per million. And then I thought I'd close the window so that, you know, if someone starts mowing their lawn outside, it wouldn't bother our conversation.
他们说的是，那些海滩将在 7 月 4 日开放。基本上就是这样。所以这花的时间太长了，但最终我们认识到新冠肺炎是一种空气传播的感染。这种认识导致了我们行为的一些改变，你知道的，
And it's gone up to 746 parts per million since we've been talking. That's just my own carbon dioxide. I mean, this strikes me as super funny to me because the inventor of measuring CO2 and who sort of pioneered that. And in fact, the sort of count of CO2, the Pettencalfour number, is Max von Pettencalfour. The myasmatist, you know, the last standing miasmatist. It is crazy. It is crazy. This guy who was, yeah, was willing to drink cholera bacteria to prove his miasma theory.
比如户外就餐和戴口罩。但你个人对生活方式做出的改变我觉得挺酷的。你能谈谈你现在随身携带的小装置吗，它可以帮助你测量室内空间的通风水平？我身上带着一个二氧化碳监测仪，我现在正看着它。所以当我们开始谈话时，我把窗户开着，因为这里今天天气很好，读数是百万分之 441。然后我想我把窗户关上，这样，你知道，如果有人开始在外面割草，就不会打扰我们的谈话。
That's what we call it now. We still call it the peten cougher number. And really because it serves as this useful analog for something else. It's not like you're measuring the amount of bacteria or virus. is in the, you're just measuring the CO2 load, which means it's gone through your body and expelled again? Yeah. So, so Pettenkofer, Maxwell and Pettencalfer thought that he couldn't directly measure the miasmas.
自从我们开始谈话以来，它已经上升到百万分之 746。这只是我自己的二氧化碳。我的意思是，这让我觉得超级有趣，因为发明测量二氧化碳并开创这一先河的人。事实上，二氧化碳的计数，即佩滕科弗指数，就是马克斯·冯·佩滕科弗。瘴气论者，你知道，最后一位坚守的瘴气论者。这太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。这个家伙，是的，愿意喝下霍乱细菌来证明他的瘴气理论。
So he would use carbon dioxide as a proxy for the ventilation in a room. You know, he could say a room that has high CO2 is poorly ventilated and therefore can be dangerous if there are fumes that rise in. to it. We can use our carbon dioxide meters to also measure the ventilation in rooms. And if it's a poorly ventilated room and there are a lot of people, the carbon dioxide level is going to build up. And along with that, so are the little droplets that we exhale. And if somebody in the room has got COVID or has got tuberculosis or it's got the flu, it's got measles, I got a whole set of airborne diseases, the risk that you will get sick goes up.
这就是我们现在称呼它的方式。我们仍然称之为佩滕科弗数。真的，因为它可以用作其他东西的有用模拟。这不像你在测量空气中细菌或病毒的数量，你只是在测量二氧化碳的负荷，这意味着它已经通过你的身体并再次呼出了？是的。所以，佩滕科弗，马克斯·冯·佩滕科弗认为他无法直接测量瘴气。
So when your CO2 meter gets to the Pettenkofer number above that number where you're uncomfortable, what do you do? If I'm on a plane and, you know, I'm not able to get off of it, I will break out my mask, you know, an N95 respirator because I know from lots of research that scientists have done, that N95 respirators are really good at preventing you from inhaling airborne viruses or bacteria or what have you. That seems like a very responsible course of action to put on a mask if you notice the number coming up. But should we demand a world in which the expectation is that this number shouldn't get up that high, you know, to begin with, or that the built environment should be
所以他会用二氧化碳作为房间通风的代理指标。你知道，他可以说二氧化碳含量高的房间通风不良，因此如果有气味上升，可能会很危险。我们也可以使用我们的二氧化碳监测仪来测量房间的通风情况。如果这是一个通风不良且人很多的房间，二氧化碳水平就会积聚。随之而来的是我们呼出的微小飞沫。如果房间里有人得了新冠肺炎或结核病或流感、麻疹，有一整套空气传播的疾病，你生病的风险就会上升。
taken care of us in some way? Absolutely. If you are looking at at a carbon dioxide meter, and it's going up over a thousand parts per million, I mean, that's telling you that we're dealing with a systemic failure. We're dealing with a failure to protect the air for all of us. This air in our indoor spaces, we share it. So, you know, we want to find ways to actually make that air healthier for everybody. And there are are lots of ways that you can do that. So one of the interesting ideas in your book is, you know, once we have determined, you know, that the air, the indoor air in particular, is full of this aerobiome that could make us
所以，当你的二氧化碳监测仪达到佩滕科弗数或高于你感到不舒服的那个数字时，你会怎么做？如果我在飞机上，你知道，我无法离开，我会拿出我的口罩，你知道，N95 呼吸器，因为我从科学家做过的大量研究中得知，N95 呼吸器在防止你吸入空气传播的病毒或细菌等方面真的非常有效。如果你注意到数字上升，戴上口罩似乎是一个非常负责任的做法。但我们是否应该要求这样一个世界：人们对这个数字一开始就不应该升得那么高抱有期望，或者说建筑环境应该在某种程度上照顾我们？绝对的。如果你正在看着
sick, is that we should think of it. Like we think of tap water, getting clean water. Like if there was, if tap water was spreading a disease, we would fix that problem right away. Should we be thinking about air in this way? Absolutely. Absolutely. Yes. And many of the scientists who led the charge to get the world to recognize that COVID is airborne have been continuing to fight for clean air. They have proposed a whole set of benchmarks that buildings should meet in order to ensure that we're not at really great risk of getting sick so that we don't have these super spreader events. And so how do we do that?
二氧化碳监测仪，它正升到百万分之一千以上，我的意思是，这在告诉你我们正在面对系统性失败。我们在未能保护我们所有人的空气方面遭遇了失败。我们在室内空间的空气，我们共享它。所以，你知道，我们想要找到方法来让每个人的空气更健康。有很多方法可以做到这一点。所以你书中的一个有趣观点是，你知道，一旦我们确定了，你知道，室内空气特别是充满了可能让我们生病的空气微生物组，我们就应该这样看待它。就像我们对待自来水一样，获取干净的水。就像如果自来水在传播疾病，我们会立即解决这个问题。我们应该以这种方式思考空气吗？绝对的。绝对的。是的。许多带头让世界认识到新冠是通过空气传播的科学家一直在为清洁空气而战。他们提出了一整套建筑物应该达到的基准，以确保我们没有真正感染疾病的高风险，这样我们就不会发生这些超级传播事件。那么我们该怎么做呢？
Like, how do we move towards a world where healthy air is an expectation the way clean water is an expectation? Well, I mean, I think to begin with, people need to monitor the air. And then if you've got a space that was built poorly and is poorly ventilated, you've got to find out ways to make them better ventilated. Back in, you know, the 1800s, New York City said, okay, we're chopping windows into buildings. Right. We don't necessarily have to do that. but, you know, there are ways to retrofit buildings so that you can bring in more fresh air to mix into the ventilation systems. That's one way. You can use filters, you know, like hepa filters
比如，我们如何走向这样一个世界：呼吸健康的空气就像拥有干净的水一样，成为一种理所当然的期望？嗯，我的意思是，首先，人们需要监测空气。然后，如果某个建筑空间建造粗糙且通风不良，你就必须找出改善其通风的方法。你知道，早在19世纪，纽约市就规定，好吧，我们要给建筑物开窗。没错。我们不一定非得这样做，但是，你知道，有一些方法可以对建筑物进行改造，以便引入更多新鲜空气，将其混合到通风系统中。这是一种方法。你可以使用过滤器，你知道，比如高效微粒过滤器（HEPA）
and other types of filters. Those work. In some circumstances, ultraviolet light might actually work really well. There still needs to be more testing to really, you know, nail down the best way to use it. But we've known since the 1930s that ultraviolet light can disinfect air. So that that could be another tool. And then when new buildings are built, you know, they need to take these facts into consideration. It's a lot easier to build a healthy building than it is to try to retrofit a sick building. You know, building engineers and building engineers societies are thinking about these issues very seriously and some of them are implementing these things into their building's designs, which is great. But, you know, it's just on a sort of case-by-case basis. You know, you don't
和其他类型的过滤器。这些都是管用的。在某些情况下，紫外线实际上可能效果非常好。要真正确定使用它的最佳方法，仍然需要进行更多的测试。但我们自20世纪30年代以来就知道紫外线可以消毒空气。所以这可能是另一个工具。然后，当建造新建筑时，你知道，他们需要把这些事实考虑进去。建造一个健康的建筑，比试图去改造一个有问题的建筑要容易得多。你知道，建筑工程师和建筑工程师协会正在非常认真地思考这些问题，其中一些人正在将这些东西应用到他们的建筑设计中，这很棒。但是，你知道，这只是按个案进行的。你知道，你不会
walk into some building and go into a bathroom and, you know, washing your hands, thinking, well, I hope this building, you know, has clean water that won't give me cholera, you know. You don't say that because you don't have to say it because there are standards for that. So there's no country in the world yet that has standards along the lines that I'm talking about. I mean, could there be standards for indoor air quality that could be met? Oh, yeah, yeah. No, I mean, these scientists who championed recognizing COVID as airborne, they have come out with proposed standards to meet. There have been model bills that have been drafted at Johns Hopkins University. It's all in place that it can all go, but there is still a lot
走进某个建筑物的洗手间，洗着手，心里想着，嗯，我希望这个建筑物的（水）有干净的水，不会让我得霍乱，你知道的。你不会那样说，因为你不需要说，因为有这方面的标准。所以世界上还没有哪个国家有我所说的这种标准。我的意思是，会不会有可以达到的室内空气质量标准？哦，会，会的。不，我的意思是，那些倡导承认新冠病毒是通过空气传播的科学家们，已经提出了需要达到的拟议标准。约翰斯·霍普金斯大学已经起草了示范法案。一切都已就绪，随时可以推行，但仍然存在很多
of inertia. I mean, this seems like a real call to arms and a provocation for architects and designers in particular. Like, you know, like to make this central to the way that they're designing our built world is to prepare us for this. Yeah, absolutely. I mean, we were in a bad position when COVID hit in 2020 because so many of our buildings and our spaces were poorly ventilated and were just great places for this virus to build up and go from one person to another spreading around like smoke. I mean, that was, you know, that's one of the particular cruelties of diseases like COVID
阻力。我的意思是，这似乎是对建筑师和设计师的一个真正的集结号和激发。比如，你知道，把这作为他们设计我们建造的世界的核心，以此来为我们做好准备。是的，绝对的。我的意思是，当2020年新冠疫情来袭时，我们处境糟糕，因为我们的许多建筑和空间通风不良，简直是这种病毒积聚并从一个人传给另一个人、像烟雾一样四处蔓延的绝佳场所。我的意思是，那是，你知道，那是像新冠这样的疾病特有的残酷之处之一
because they pray on us when we come together. I do think we deserve to enjoy each other's company and not just out in the park. Outside is fine, but inside is important too. And there are ways that we can make that experience safer. And that will help us for diseases that we deal with sort of on a day-to-day basis now, like familiar diseases. And we do have to think about the next pandemic
因为它们在我们聚集在一起时趁虚而入。我确实认为我们理应享受彼此的陪伴，而不仅仅是在公园里。室外固然很好，但室内也很重要。我们可以通过一些方法让这种体验更安全。这将有助于我们应对现在日常生活中经常处理的疾病，比如熟悉的疾病。我们确实必须考虑下一场大流行
because, unfortunately, there will be one. And, you know, if it's airborne, the way COVID was, that will really turbocharge it and make it, you know, particularly bad. It is definitely a wake-up call. And, I mean, you know, this wake-up call started in most recently in 2020. So we've had five years of wake-up call. So it's time to stop hitting the snooze button on it. It's time to wake up and start to build safer buildings. So one of the final scenes of this book is at Club Cafe in Boston.
因为不幸的是，大流行还会发生。而且，你知道，如果它像新冠病毒那样通过空气传播，那真的会给它按上涡轮增压器，让它变得特别严重。这绝对是一个警钟。而且，我的意思是，你知道，这个警钟最近在2020年敲响。所以我们已经经历了五年的警钟。因此，是时候停止按贪睡按钮了。是时候醒来，开始建造更安全的建筑了。所以这本书的最后一个场景之一是在波士顿的俱乐部咖啡馆（Club Cafe）。
And it is kind of doing some of the things. things that you are recommending in terms of how to make our air biome safe for us. Can you describe what it's like there and what they're doing? So in working on the book, I got to know a retired tuberculosis expert named Ed Nardell. And he had worked a lot in using ultraviolet light to protect homeless shelters when there were tuberculosis outbreaks happening. So Ed, in his retirement, discovers he really likes to sing, he likes to sing cabaret songs. And there's this club called a club cafe where every week in a little space called the Napoleon Room, people get together and there's a piano in there and they take turns singing songs. So after
它在某种程度上正在做你推荐的一些事情，以使我们的空气生物群落对我们安全。你能描述一下那里的情况以及他们在做什么吗？在写这本书的过程中，我认识了一位退休的结核病专家，名叫埃德·纳德尔（Ed Nardell）。他曾大量使用紫外线来保护结核病爆发时的无休庇护所。所以埃德在退休后发现自己真的很喜欢唱歌，他喜欢唱卡巴莱歌。有一个叫俱乐部咖啡馆（Club Cafe）的地方，每周在一个叫拿破仑厅（Napoleon Room）的小空间里，人们聚在一起，里面有一台钢琴，他们轮流唱歌。所以
people got vaccinated, you know, Ed was thinking, well, like, we need to get back together. We need to get together. And so he talked the club into letting him install these little far UBC lights on the ceiling in the Napoleon room. And far UVC lights are this new kind of ultraviolet light fixture that you talk about in the book. They can still disinfect the air, but they're designed in such a way that they won't burn your skin or hurt you. That's right. And that would be, you know, the ultimate safe space. You could go in there, you could sing, and you could be pretty confident
人们接种疫苗后，你知道，埃德在想，嗯，我们得重新聚在一起。我们需要聚在一起。于是他说服俱乐部让他在拿破仑厅的天花板上安装了这些远紫外线（Far-UVC）小灯。远紫外线灯是你书中所述的一种新型紫外线灯具。它们仍然可以给空气消毒，但它们的射设计使得它们不会灼伤你的皮肤或伤害你。没错。这将是，你知道的，终极的安全空间。你可以进去，你可以唱歌，你可以非常有信心地认为
that you wouldn't get sick from COVID. And he invited me along to join him one night. So me and my wife came, and we had a great time singing away and just enjoying this experience with other folks, quite confident that we were not going to get COVID while we were there. And we didn't.
你不会因为新冠而生病。他邀请我陪他一起去过一个晚上。于是我和我妻子去了，我们玩得很开心，载歌载舞，和其他人一起享受这段经历，相当确信我们在那里不会感染新冠。而我们确实没有感染。
And, you know, Ed is not aware of anybody who has gotten COVID coming to the Napoleon room for these performances. So, you know, I think that gives you a picture of what life could be like taking airborne disease seriously. It doesn't mean that we have to be all in lockdown, in total isolation, and being really depressed. We can get together. We can do stuff.
而且，你知道，埃德并不知道有谁在来拿破仑厅看这些演出时感染了新冠。所以，你知道，我认为这让你了解到认真对待空气传播疾病的生活会是什么样子。这并不意味着我们必须全部处于封锁状态、完全孤立并且非常沮丧。我们可以聚在一起。我们可以做事。
We can sing. We can have a good time. we just need to take the right precautions. Yeah. Carl Zimmer, thank you so much for talking with me. I enjoyed the book so much. There's so many details in the book that we didn't cover, but I just, so I encourage people to read it. It's so much fun. Thank you so much for talking with me. Oh, thank you so much for having me. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald, mixed by Martine Gonzales,
我们可以唱歌。我们可以玩得很开心。我们只需要采取正确的预防措施。是的。卡尔·齐默（Carl Zimmer），非常感谢你与我交谈。我非常喜欢这本书。书中有太多我们没有涵盖的细节，但我只想说，我鼓励大家去读它。太有趣了。非常感谢你跟我谈话。哦，非常感谢邀请我。本周的《99%无形》（99% Invisible）由埃梅特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）制作，由马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martine Gonzales）混音，
music by Swan Real and George Langford. And hey, just a heads up, Emmett is going to be interviewing author and 99PI contributor Sam Block at the Commonwealth Club in San Francisco on Tuesday, July 29th. They'll be talking all about Sam's fantastic new book, which is called Shade, The Promise of a Forgotten Natural Resource. If you're in the Bay Area, you should totally check it out. Kathy Two is our executive producer. Kurt Colstead is the digital director.
音乐由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）和乔治·兰福德（George Langford）创作。嘿，顺便提醒一下，埃梅特将于7月29日星期二在旧金山的联邦俱乐部（Commonwealth Club）采访作家兼《99PI》撰稿人萨姆·布洛克（Sam Block）。他们将讨论萨姆那本名为《树荫：被遗忘的自然资源的承诺》（Shade, The Promise of a Forgotten Natural Resource）的精彩新书。如果你在湾区，你绝对应该去看看。凯西·图（Kathy Two）是我们的执行制作人。库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监。
Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barubei, Jason Dillard. Leone, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lashma Don, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Series XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as your own Discord server. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99 PM.
德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝伊（Chris Barubei）、杰森·迪拉德（Jason Dillard）、莱昂尼（Leone）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、维维安·莱（Vivian Lay）、拉什马·唐（Lashma Don）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森（Jacob Medina Gleason）以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。《99%无形》的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作的。我们是天狼星XM（Series XM）播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在北边六个街区外的潘多拉大厦（Pandora building）。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及你自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有一个链接，包含了99PI过去的每一集节目。
at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。